ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE HEARING I'M SORRY FOR
STARTING LATE --
YES FIFTY SEVEN BILLS TO
CONSIDER.
THIS MORNING SO I'M HOPING THAT
PEOPLE ARE ONLY PRESENTING ON
BILLS THAT NEED TO BE PRESENTED
ON AND AS ALWAYS WILL HAVE TO
WITNESSES --
IN SUPPORT TO IN OPPOSITION HAD
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH
WITH THAT WE ARE STARTING AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE BECAUSE I AT THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM --
WITHOUT MISTER MONEY.
MISTER MONNING I'M NOT SURE WHAT
DO YOU PRESENTED ON AND I AM
WHIMS PRESENTING ON S. B.. TEN
SEVENTY NINE AS AMENDED IN S. B..
ELEVEN NINETY TWO THEN I HAVE
SOME CONSENT ITEMS --
SEVEN SIXTY SIX NINE NINETY
SEVEN THOSE HER ON CONSENT AND
ELEVEN THIRTEEN NO PRESENTATION
ON THOSE.
SO IF I COULD PROCEED WITH JUST
A SHORT SUMMARY OF S. B..
THREE NINETY EIGHT THINK YOU.
OF THIS EXTENDS THE SUNSET DATE
FOR THE TRAUMATIC BRAIN INJURY
PROGRAM TO JULY FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR PROGRAM WAS
ESTABLISHED IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY PROGRAM PROVIDES
GRANTS TO COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS THAT COURTNEY
SERVICES TO ASSISTED THOUGHTS
WHEN ACQUIRED.
TBI.
THE DEPARTMENT OF REHAB
ADMINISTERS THE PROGRAM AND
THEY'RE CURRENTLY SEVEN TBI
SERVICE PROVIDERS AROUND THE
STATE.
I TB I PROGRAM HAS SERVED
THOUSANDS OF TBI SURVIVORS.
LOOTING WAR VETERANS IN ASSISTED
WITH THE REHABILITATION
INDEPENDENT LIVING.
IT'S BEEN EXTREMELY EFFECTIVE
WITH VERY LIMITED RESOURCES AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME WHEN
SUSPENSE IS CONSIDERED I'D ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE TO CONTINUE THIS
VITAL PROGRAM FOR CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE SUPPORTERS.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE.
OF METAL ME DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
WE ARE UP TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT CREATES A GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE.
THE LEAST A MILLION DOLLARS TO
CONTINUE FUNDING FOR THE PROGRAM
FOR AN ADDITIONAL FIVE YEARS.
OF PROGRAM ACTIVITIES ARE
CURRENTLY SUPPORTED BY A
TRANSFER OF FUNDS FROM THE STATE
PENLEY FUND. TO THE TRAUMATIC
BRAIN INJURY FUND.
THAT TWO THOUSAND EIGHT EIGHTEEN
BUDGET ACT INCLUDES EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THIS OF FUN FOR THE DEPARTMENTS.
BRAIN INJURY FUND PROGRAM BUT%
CANNOT CURRENTLY SUPPORT AN
APPROPRIATION OF ANY SIZE.
IN.
NINETEEN TWENTY THINK HUMANE AND
TWENTY TWENTY UP IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR RIGHT. TWENTY NINE
TWENTY NINETEEN AND RIGHT
[inaudible]
TWENTY TWENTY RIGHT.
GOING BACK IN TIME [inaudible]
WE GOT.
WILL MOVE OUT OF THIS IS THANK
YOU THINK JUST A BRIEF REACTION
TO THAT CHEFS WAS MOVED FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF MENTAL HEALTH.
A DRAMATIC BRAIN INJURY IS NOT A
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITION. TO
DEPARTMENT OF REHAB --
WITH THE SUNSET AS ESTABLISHED.
BUT THE OPPOSITION TO CONTINUING
IT WHEN IT GETS INIMAL EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND A YEAR WILL
LEAVE A LOT OF FAMILIES WITHOUT
ANY OPTION SO AGAIN I APPRECIATE
YOU LETTING ME JUST OFFER A
COMMENT ON THAT.
THANK YOU AND NOW MADAM CHAIR
SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY NINE
ADVANCE PAYMENTS FOR FORCED
GRANTS ADDICTS START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
YOU GONNA COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
THAT --
MEMBER SENATE BILL TEN SEVENTY
NINE AUTHORIZES THE DIRECTOR OF
CAL FIRE TO ALLOW ADVANCE
PAYMENTS FOR THE FORCE HEALTH
GRANT IN FIRE PREVENTION FUND
GRANT PROGRAMS.
AS WE KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCING LARGER MORE INTENSE
WILDFIRE THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
HELLFIRE HAS CHANGED ITS POLICY
TO REQUIRE NON PROFITS SPECIAL
DISTRICTS AND LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT RECEIVE FORCED HELP THEM
FIRE PREVENTION GRANTS. TO BE
REIMBURSED.
BECAUSE REIMBURSEMENTS GENERALLY
TAKE BETWEEN SIXTY TO NINETY
DAYS A DELAY AND FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP CAN BE CREATED.
S. B. TEN SEVENTY NINE THIS
TIMELESS CAO FIRES CURRENTLY
DISBURSING.
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN GRANT PROGRAM
FUNDS -- I
HAVE WITH THIS TO TESTIFY
[inaudible]
THINK [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
I PLEASE DON'T MADAM CHAIR WITH
YOUR PERMISSION --
REPRESENTED OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT SURE IF WE
CAN HOLD FOR JUST A MINUTES WE
CAN ESTABLISH A CLIMB --
THEN WE'LL GET BACK TO THE
TESTIMONY AND SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL [inaudible]
GONZALEZ FLETCHER [inaudible]
BIGELOW [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BONTA [inaudible]
BROUGH [inaudible]
CALDERON [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
JEFF [inaudible]
EGGMAN FRIEDMAN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
I FEAR.
THIS AREA.
OBERNOLTE.
QUIRK HERE RAISE YOUR THANK YOU
MAY PERCEIVE.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON BY MISS RACE
IN A SECOND BY MISS CARILLO.
YES IT KNOW THIS IS A DO PASS AS
AMENDED [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
OKAY.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SARAH SHAMAR
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF RESOURCE
CONSERVATION DISTRICTS.
THE NINETY EIGHT OUR CITIES
AROUND THE STATE.
EMPLOYMENT ON THE GROUND
CONSERVATION WITH A COMMUNITY
FOCUS.
WE ADDRESS STATEWIDE
CONSERVATION.
CONCERNS WITH THE LOCAL MISSION.
THE THREAT OF WILDFIRE LIKE MANY
RESOURCE CONCERNS HAS A CRITICAL
LOCAL COMPONENT.
COMMUNITIES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
REDUCE FUEL LOADS.
MANAGE FORCE APPROPRIATELY
CREATE FUEL BREAKS AND EDUCATE
MEMBERS ON US SAFE EVACUATION
ROUTES.
THIS MUST HAPPEN AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL LANDOWNER TO LANDOWNER.
THIS TAKES THE WORK OF LOCAL
GROUPS LIKE THE RCTS LIKE FIRE
SAFE COUNCILS AND OTHER LOCAL
ENTITIES AND THESE GROUPS HAVE
LIMITED BUDGETS.
WHEN I TALK TO OUR CITIES AND
OTHER LOCAL GROUPS AROUND THE
STATE AND ASK THEM WHAT'S THE
ONE THING THAT WE COULD DO? TO
MAKE THEIR JOBS EASIER.
THE NUMBER ONE RESPONSE IS
ADVANCE PAYMENTS TO TAKE AWAY
THE BURDEN OF CASH FLOW.
WITH THE ACCOUNTABILITY
PROVISIONS OUTLINED IN THIS BILL
THE STATE CAN BE ASSURED THAT
GOOD WORK WILL GET DONE.
AND THAT LOCAL GROUPS WILL BE
ACCOUNTABLE PARTICULARLY WHEN
GOING THROUGH LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU FOR CONSIDERING THIS
BILL AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE ON
BEHALF THIS SAN LUIS OBISPO
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT ASK FOR I DON'T THINK
YOU [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE PART AND FINANCE.
GOOD MORNING TO TELL ME ASSURE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL HARTLEY NOTE.
ON THAT THE BILL MAY DRIVE
ADDITIONAL COSTS FOR COAL FIRED
TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES FOR
ISSUING ADVANCE PAYMENTS AND TO
TRACK IN OVERSEE ADVANCE
PAYMENTS AFTER THEY HAVE BEEN
ISSUED.
HOWEVER WE'VE ONLY LOOKED AT THE
JUNE FOURTEENTH VERSION OF DON'T
HAVE MUCH IN [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND YOU HAVE ACCEPTED THE
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK IT'S
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THINKING THIS
MORNING.
YOU HAVE ELEVEN NINETY TWO AS
WELL YES AT ALSO ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER IS THE SECOND
BY MISTER QUIRK IN THE PRESENT
THANK YOU.
I'LL BE BRIEF MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS --
CALIFORNIANS DIETARY HABITS HAVE
CHANGED GREATLY IN THE LAST FEW
DECADES.
WITH MORE MORE OF OUR FOOD
BUDGETS BEING SPENT ON FOOD
PREPARED OUTSIDE THE HOME.
MOST MEALS OFFERED AND MARKETED
TO CHILDREN REST READ DRINK
WHICH OFTEN CONTAINS MORE THAN
THE WEEKLY AMOUNT OF SUGAR
RECOMMENDED FOR CHILDREN.
MANY RESTAURANTS AND FAST FOOD
ESTABLISHMENTS HOWEVER HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN STEPS CHANGE WHAT
BEVERAGES THEY OFFER IN THEIR
KIDS MEALS.
RESTAURANTS LIKE MCDONALD'S JACK
IN THE BOX APPLEBEE'S AND I HOP
HAVE ALL VOLUNTARILY MADE
EFFORTS TO OFFER MORE HEALTHFUL
BEVERAGE OPTIONS FOR CHILDREN.
SENATE BILL ELEVEN NINETY TWO
FOLLOWS THE LEAD OF THE
RESTAURANT INDUSTRY AND
IMPLEMENTS A STATEWIDE HELPFUL
DEFAULT BEVERAGE POLICY IN
CALIFORNIA.
WHICH WILL REQUIRE A RESTAURANT
THAT SERVES A MEAL PRIMARILY
OFFERED FOR CONSUMPTION BY
CHILDREN. TO MAKE THE DEFAULT
DRINK OPTIONS SERVED IN THOSE
BUNDLED MEALS A HEALTHFUL
BEVERAGE SUCH AS WATER SPARKLING
WATER FLAVORED WATER WITH NO
ADDED SWEETENERS OR UNFLAVORED
MILK.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
CUSTOMERS CAN STILL.
EXPLICITLY ASK TO REPLACE THE
HELPFUL DRINK WITH A SUGARY
BEVERAGE BUT THE DEFAULT
BEVERAGE OFFERED IN A CHILDREN'S
MEAL.
MUST BE A HEALTHFUL OPTION.
MEMBERS PUBLIC HEALTH POLICIES
LIKE THE ONE FOUND IN THIS BILL
CAN HAVE A DIRECT IMPACT IN
EDUCATING PARENTS ABOUT THE
SEVERE CHRONIC HEALTH IMPACTS.
SUGAR SWEETENED BEVERAGES ON
THEIR CHILDREN.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
WITNESS INSPIRED.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS DOCTOR
FLOWS ON CO FOR AND I AM THE
DIRECTOR OF STATE POLICY AND
RESEARCH FOR PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES.
I AM PLEASED TO JOIN THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
AMERICAN STROKE ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ALLIANCE OF
YMCAS THE LATINO COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND MOM'S
RISING TO CO SPONSOR SB.
ELEVEN NINETY TWO AS YOU'RE
AWARE WE HAVE AN OBESITY
EPIDEMIC IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
DRIVEN BY THE CONSUMPTION OF
SUGARY DRINKS SUGARY DRINKS OF
THE LARGEST SOURCE OF ADDED
SUGAR IN OUR DIETS.
ANY THEY COME WITH HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES A CHILD WHO
CONSUMES JUST WANNA SUGARY DRINK
A DAY INCREASES THE RISK OF
BEING OVERWEIGHT OR OBESE BY 55%.
THE RISK OF HAVING DIABETES BY
26% AND DOUBLES THE RISK OF
HAVING CAVITIES SO THIS IS A
MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERN.
AND SO EACH OF THE CO SPONSORS
HERE TODAY REALLY FOCUS ON THE
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR HEALTH AND WE
SEE THIS AS AN ENVIRONMENTAL
BILL A BILL THAT CHANGES THE
RETAIL FOOD ENVIRONMENT BY
CHANGING WHAT IS WHAT IS DONE BY
DEFAULT.
I OFTEN TELL THE STORY OF
COOKIES THAT IF I BROUGHT
COOKIES TO YOU THIS MORNING OR
DONUTS SINCE WE'RE HERE IN THE
MORNING MANY OF YOU WOULD HAVE A
DONUT AND NONE OF YOU WOULD HAVE
ASKED ME FOR A DONUT OTHERWISE
AND YOU'D HAVE A DONUT BECAUSE
IT WAS.
HERE AND THAT'S THE INFLUENCE OF
THE ENVIRONMENT AND MANY OF US
DO WHAT HAPPENS BY DEFAULT AND
SO THIS BILL IS REALLY CHANGING
THAT SO WE'RE MAKING THE HEALTHY
CHOICE THE EASY CHOICE.
BY NOT PRIMING CHILDREN TO
CONSUME SUGARY DRINKS.
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION THE
IMPLEMENTATION COSTS ARE ARE
NEGLIGIBLE --
TO SMALL BUSINESSES AND LARGE
BUSINESSES AND THE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS THE STATE
ARE QUITE SMALL BECAUSE THIS IS
BEING PULLED IN FOLDED INTO
EXISTING ADMINISTRATIVE
OVERSIGHT BY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH DIRECTORS.
SO WE SEE THIS AS A BILL THAT IS
SMART THAT RELIEVED TRULY
PROTECTS PUBLIC HEALTH AND WE'VE
ALSO TAKEN AMENDMENTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT FOR A SMALL BUSINESS
IS THE FIRST VIOLATION IS
ACTUALLY JUST A WARNING IT'S
SORT OF A FIX THAT TICKET.
BECAUSE THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO
PENALIZE BUSINESSES THE GOAL
REALLY IS TO GET THEM TO BE PART
OF THE SOLUTION AND BEING ABLE
TO ADDRESS CHILDREN'S HEALTH.
SMALL CHANGES TO THE ENVIRONMENT
CAN MAKE A REALLY BIG IMPACT AND
SO WE WANT TO HAVE MORE SECONDS
I'M SO I GUESS WE ONE OF THE
KIDS GROWING UP --
NOT SEEN THESE BEVERAGES AND
BEING PRIME SO I I STRONGLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU AYE I'M HOPING AND
LEAVE A LOT OF BILLS TODAY AND I
DO APPRECIATE THE PRESENTATION
BUT WE'RE GONNA TRY TO KEEP
COMMENTS TO THE A SCHOOL ISSUE --
BECAUSE THIS IS.
TECHNICALLY NOT POLICY COMMITTEE.
MADAM CHAIR JUST LOAN FOR THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTORS ON THE FISCAL ISSUE
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS MAKE IT SO
MUCH EASIER FOR US TO ENFORCE
THE BILL SO WE THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THOSE AMENDMENTS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORTED.
THANK YOU OFFICIAL SUPPORTERS
CHAIR MEMBERS KATHY MUST WITH
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
COSPONSORED YOUR SUPPORT.
THAT CHAIR JASON BROWN WE HAVE
KEPT WESTERN UNITED DAIRY MEN
APPRECIATE DECLARED ABOUT WHAT
TYPE OF MILK PRODUCTS WOULD
QUALIFY THE BILL WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT.
MY EXPERIENCE CITY OF LONG BEACH
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS BETSEY
ARMSTRONG A BEHALF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA'S LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MERGER SPORT.
CHRIS SLIPPED WALLY CALIFORNIA
STATE ALLIANCE OF YMCAS CO
SPONSORS.
MICHAEL HIM TELL OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
SEE NOT DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
WE KNOW THAT BY CREATING AN
INFRACTION PUNISHABLE BY
INCREASING FINDS THIS BILL COULD
IMPOSE NEW BUT LIKELY MINIMAL
COSTS AND WORKLOAD ON COUNTIES
WHICH CREATES ADDITIONAL FISCAL
PRESSURES ON THE LOCAL CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ADDITIONALLY WE NOTE MINOR AN
OBSERVABLE COST LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AGENCIES TO
ENFORCE THE NEW RETAIL COULD
PROVISIONS.
HOWEVER ANY NEW COSTA ENTITIES
WOULD INCUR WOULD BE COVERED FOR
PERMITTING FEES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANY COMMENTS AS A
PARENT -- I
THINK YOU FOR THIS BILL.
WE ALL KNOW IT'S EASIER IF THE
MENU STARTS WITH --
WATER.
SEVERAL CHOICES AND HOPEFULLY
IT'LL DEVELOP HABITS --
FOR PARENTS IN ORDERING FOR
CHILDREN AS THEY MOVE FORWARD SO
THAT'LL BE MY CLOTHES
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU I THINK DID WE GET A
MOTION ON THAT BILL.
WE DID.
YES MISS RARE SET A SECOND BY
MISTER QUIRK.
I AND I GET OUT OF THE ROLL CALL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
MEMBERS
.
THAT CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRISON.
IF OPERATIONS CLAIMS BILL.
WHICH IS A STANDARD BILL THAT WE
USUALLY DO EACH YEAR.
YES YOU LIKE TO FURTHER EXPLAIN
THAT THAT IS THE BILL I HAVE.
WE HAVE WE HAVE A WILLIAM.
UNLESS A MAN A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK -- FOR
THIS BILL ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
A DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
SUPPORTS THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
ESTABLISHES THE PREPARATION
AUTHORITY NECESSARY FOR THE
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD TO PAY
A CLAIM IT'S BEEN APPROVED.
THE BILL APPROPRIATES A NINETY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS OF GENERAL
FUND FOR THE PAYMENT OF A CLAIM
[inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION [inaudible]
ONSITE.
AT A ROLL CALL.
FORGOT WHICH COMMITTEE I WAS IN
FROM.
BUT I FEEL CAUGHT THAT.
ONE ALRIGHT AT THIS POINT WE
HAVE NO AUTHORS HERE --
SO IF THERE ARE AND WERE LOOKING.
FOR LOOKS LIKE MISS JACKSON AND
ANNABETH JACKS AND MISTER HILL
MISS LEYVA OR MISTER HERNANDEZ.
WE'RE GONNA GIVE THEM.
A FEW MINUTES BUT MISTER MCGUIRE
.
ALRIGHT WE'LL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SECOND WE MUCH MY DISMAY LOW
SECOND FIVE THAT MR QUIRK --
MEMSIC TAKING PLEASE.
READ OFF THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIS BE. SEVENTY FOR NINETY FIVE
WITHIN MINUTES 532-688-7668
1-692-929-9402 NINE NINETY SEVEN
ONE THOUSAND THREE WITHOUT THE
421-000-9811 THIRTEEN OF THE
TWENTY THREE ELEVEN NINETY NINE
TWELVE A 812-271-23212.
591-280-1330 ONE THIRTEEN SIXTY
THREE FIFTEEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTEEN OF THANK YOU ARE LIKE
IT'S OUT ON ME A ROLL CALL AND
WE WILL NOW AND MEN SURGERY READ
THE BILLS THAT ARE BEING MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE CALENDAR.
S. B.. 383-826-2350 FOUR THREE
NINETY EIGHT FOUR THIRTY NINE
BIBLE TO BUY THE TEAM
695-740-6830. 583-689-6933 NINE
EIGHTY NINE TO NO FIVE TO NINETY
SEVEN ELEVEN NO 612-261-29213
201-340-81390 FIVE NSC ARE.
ONE FIFTY SO AT THIS POINT WE
ARE GOING TO DEEM ALL OF THOSE
PRESENTATIONS WAY IT --
SO AND IF ANYONE SHOWS UP TO
PRESENT ON THE SUSPENSE FIVE ALL
THOSE HAVE PRESENTATIONS HAVE
BEEN WAIVED IF YOU'RE HERE AND
WANT TO REGISTER.
YOUR SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO
ANY OF THOSE BELLS NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME TO COME FORWARD AND DO
SO.
ALRIGHT SEEN NONE OF THAT
[inaudible]
MR HILL.
MR HILL YOU'LL BE PRESENTING
ONLY ON S. B. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN S. B. ELEVEN OF SIX IS OUR
EVEN MOVE DISPENSED WHILE YOU
WAIT PRESENTATION.
IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION. FOURTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD PROTECT VETERANS AND
MILITARY PERSONNEL FROM HOUSING
DISCRIMINATION ENSURE THAT
LANDLORDS CANNOT DENY HOMELESS
VETERANS HOUSING BASED.
SOLELY ON THE FACT THAT THEY
RECEIVE A RENTAL ASSISTANCE
VOUCHERS MISS ISABEL.
RECREATIONAL ABOUT MEMBERS THANK
YOU THANK YOU ARE THERE ARE
SPEAKERS IN SPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SO YOU'RE NOT POSITION OF THE
BILL [inaudible]
CORRECT OKAY.
YEAH TWO MINUTES.
PLEASE ON THE FISCAL ISSUES.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M JOHN
SCHUMACHER OF SHOWING THE
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION OF ORANGE
COUNTY AND FOR REGIONAL PARTNERS
SO SHE ASIANS.
I WANT TO MAKE CLEAR AT THE
OUTSET THAT THIS IS NOT ABOUT
VETERANS FROM OUR VIEW.
THIS IS ABOUT A PROGRAM THAT WE
FEEL IS.
INSUFFICIENT TO SUPPORT THE
PROMISES MADE [inaudible]
SO.
THE NOTION XIN THERE'S ONLY ONE
NARROW PART OF THIS BILL.
AND THAT DEALS WITH THE VOUCH
VOUCHER SYSTEM --
COMBINATION HARD SUCTION ORG
PROGRAM WAS THE VETERANS
ADMINISTRATION.
WE HAVE MEMBERS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN OUR PROGRAM.
AS A VETERAN I'M WELL AWARE OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS AND THEIR ACTIVITY XIN
FULLY SUPPORT.
THEIR MISSION.
BUT IN ORDER BUT JUDGMENT AND
THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR MEMBERS
THEY HAVE FALLEN SHORT.
IN THE SUPPORT THE DISH
PROMOTION UNDER THE VASH PROGRAM.
AS A CONSEQUENCE WE FIND EMBERS
WHO HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE
PROGRAM IN THE PAST.
AND HAVE DROPPED OUT OF THE
PROGRAM BECAUSE OF VARIOUS
DEFICIENCIES PARTICULARLY WITH
RESPECT TO DELAYS XIN INSPECTION --
DELAYS AND REPAIR.
MORE REQUIRED REPAIR.
AND DELAY IN QUALIFICATION.
SO THERE ARE MANY STEPS IN THE
PROGRAM THAT WE FIND FAULT WITH
IN SOME AREAS.
THE DIFFICULTY IS THIS IS A ONE
SHY GOOD OLE.
RESPONSE IN THE BILL. TO MANDATE.
THE ACCEPTANCE OF BASH
[inaudible]
BELCHER XIN.
IN ALL CASES AND OUR CONCERN IS.
AS SIX RUSH BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
AND IT SURE IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS [inaudible]
A MINOR.
EXPANSION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS OF THE TO TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING.
WE BELIEVE THERE WILL BE AN
ENORMOUS.
NUMBER OF CLAIMS FOR EVERY
VETERAN THAT IS DENIED HOUSING
IN THE POOL [inaudible] FOR THE
ACCEPTANCE OR NON ACCEPTANCE
[inaudible]
OF A VASH VOUCHER.
CHAU YOUR YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS
YOUR TIME IS SPENT ON THANK YOU
EVER.
EVERY DENIAL.
WILL RESULT IN A COLORABLE CLAIM
WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
OF A DENIAL BASED ON VETERAN
STATUS NOT BECAUSE OF THE VAST
PROGRAM BUT VETERAN STATUS.
NIGEL CONCERN ILLICIT DRUGS
OWNERSHIP TO A NUMBER OF
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
[inaudible]
FEAR XIN.
THANK YOU SAN ABILITY TO PERFORM
ITS FUNCTION.
THINK IS ACCURATE OR ANY OTHER
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A CREAM GREASY AND HALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS THAT WE DO HAVE AN
OPPOSE LESS AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL --
WERE OPPOSED THE MANDATORY
SECTION ACTIONS IN THE BILL --
AND HOPE TO CONTINUE WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR IN IN PURSUING
THAT DIALOGUE BUT WE DO OPPOSE
THAT PARTICULAR PART OF THE BILL
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOU
KNOW VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
SPELL HOWEVER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
ESTIMATES MINOR AN OBSERVABLE
WORKLOAD.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THIS BILL MAY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEEN NO DISCUSSION I'D ENJOY
WAYS A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISS RATES WHICH UP
CLOSE.
THINKING AT A CHURCH TO PUT
THEIR THE OPPOSITION INTO
CONTEXT THIS YEAR THERE WERE THE
STATE WAS AWARDED. TWO THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED VASH VOUCHERS OUT OF
OVER SIX MILLION HOUSING UNITS
THIS IS A DROP IN THE BUCKET I
RESPECT REACTION AYE VOTE
MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND THAT GETS OUT WITH
THE THE BILL PASSES WITH
REPUBLICANS NOT VOTING EXCEPT
MISTER OBERNOLTE WHO VOTES I
THANK YOU MANAGER VERY VERY MUCH
AND THANKS FOR INDULGING THANK
YOU [inaudible]
DR ED.
I'M SORRY DOCTOR HERNANDEZ.
YOUR PRESENT S. B. NINE TEN AND
ENJOY THE VIEW PASS
RECOMMENDATION THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS BILL MAKES IT
CLEAR THAT SHORT TERM LIMITED
DURATION HEALTH INSURANCE MAY
NOT BE SOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
URINALYSIS INDICATES IS --
NAGEL DOING COSTS ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
PICKING ENJOYS A THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION AND WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTRESS ND SECOND BY
MISS CARILLO SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MARY JANE'S FOREST
ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA COURT TO SPONSORS AT
THIS BILL PEOPLE CAN ALREADY GET
SHORT TERM COVERAGE FROM COVER
CALIFORNIA AND MEDI CAL.
AS YOUR ANALYSIS NOTED AS THE
NINE TEN WOULD HAVE KNOWLEDGE
NEGLIGIBLE IMPACTS FOR THESE
REASONS WE ASK ARRIVAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS AS PART
THINK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS JOHN
CITY ON BEHALF OF THE ALAMEDA
COUNTY PART OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I'M RICHEST AND
DAVIS AND I'M AFTER CALIFORNIA
BLACK HEALTH NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SCENE NINE DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL NO FISCAL IMPACT.
AND TO REJECT CLOSE S. FROM ITEM
CHEN THAT MAKE YOU BILL PASSES
WITH REPUBLICANS NOT PUTTING
THINK AFTER HERNANDEZ
[inaudible]
MISS LEYVA.
S.* BE WRITTEN IN AN S. B.
TWELVE FORTY FIVE ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISS RAY AS
A SECOND BY MY DOCTOR QUIRK MADE
THIS NEED THINK YOU ARE MADAM
CHAIR WITH THAT IF YOU WISH I
WOULD JUST ASK RESPECT CLASS
WHEN I VOTE.
FIGURES SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
MANAGING FORCE ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA PIECES
SUPPORT THE MEASURE BIG.
ARE THERE ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS
[inaudible]
SPEAKERS OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THIS
BILL --
COVER CALIFORNIA ESTIMATES IT'LL
BE A MINOR AND OBSERVABLE COSTS
BECAUSE THE POOL FOR PROVIDES
FOR THE CONTINUATION OF CURRENT
PROCESSES RELATING TO CERTAIN
ABOUT EMERGENCY REGULATIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SEE NO QUESTIONS REJECT CLOSE
RESPECT WESTERN AYE VOTE GET OUT
ON TO BE RECALL THINKING SLAVE
FIGURE VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU MEMBERS.
WE ARE NOW DOWN --
TO MISS HANNAH BETH JACKSON
MISTER MCGUIRE AYE THERE THOSE
TWO AUTHORS ARE THE TWO WE NEED
TO COMPLETE OUR DAY
.
ALRIGHT I'M GONNA GIVE ALSO
SENATORS --
TWO MINUTES FIVE MINUTES FIVE
MINUTES.
WE'LL DO FIVE MINUTES BEFORE WE
CLOSE DOWN IF NOT WE'LL JUST
MOVE THESE BILLS TO THE NEXT
HEARING
.
WE HAVE ABOUT TWO MORE MINUTES
WE'RE GONNA WAIT IF --
STAFF TO EITHER MISTER MCGUIRE
MISS JACKSON --
CONTACT US AND LET US KNOW IT'S
OKAY TO PRESENT THEIR BILL
SOMEBODY ON THAT.
COMMITTEE WILL PRESENT THEIR
BELT NOT WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
MOVE THESE TESTS AFTER THE BREAK.
AND HE MADE AT MISTER MCGUIRE.
ALRIGHT I'M MISTER MCGUIRE SP
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WE HAVE A
MOTION BY AND CARILLO MOVE THE
BILL AND A SECOND BY --
MISS RAYOS.
WE SHOULD PROCEED.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR OF THE
MORNING COMMITTEE I MAKE IT VERY
SHORT THANK YOU FOR THE DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION I SP FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN COMES FROM THE WORKING
GROUP THAT'S HAPPENED ALL LAST
YEAR RELATED TO GO SHIP FIRE.
FOR THIRTY FIVE INDIVIDUALS
PASSED AWAY IN THE CITY OF
OAKLAND IT BRINGS TEST THEY
DESPERATELY NEEDED REFORMS IT'S
THE FIRST OF TWO BILLS THAT ARE
MOVING THROUGH.
THE PROCESS AND WHEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WE ALSO CARRY SIMPSON
REPRESENTING THE CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER ASSOCIATION
WHO ALSO WORKS IN SECRET OVER.
HERE AS A WITNESS IN AGAIN AND
I'M SURE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SUPPORTERS.
YES GARY SIMPSON --
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF CODE
ENFORCEMENT OFFICES JUST BRIEFLY
THESE OF THE TOOLS THAT WE NEED
TO ENSURE THAT THIS TERRIBLE
TRAGEDY DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN AT
A LOCAL LEVEL SO WE REALLY.
ARE TRULY ALSO FEEL SUPPORT
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
CNN DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
HELLO WE HAVEN'T OPPOSE POSITION
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT COULD
RESULTIN CHEN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS --
CAL FIRE ESTIMATES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL TO
TOTAL TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN FIVE POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN.
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FOUR
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
ONGOING ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW
THAT THIS BILL MAY CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
BECAUSE WHILE THE BILL PROVIDES
LOCAL AGENCIES WITH THE
AUTHORITY FOR THE PROPOSED
BUILDING INSPECTIONS IT IS
UNCLEAR IF THAT AUTHORITY
EXTENDS TO THE STAFF TIME.
IS THIS AYE I'M SORRY IS THIS S.
B..
FOURTEEN FIFTEEN MENTOR THIS HAS
A HAS BEEN ONGOING COSTS A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN THE FOR THE STATE FIRE
MARSHAL THE RECEIVE BUILDING
INSPECTION REPORTS [inaudible]
YEAH I I FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN TWO
DIFFERENT WORLDS A LITTLE FAT
RIGHT.
OF THE STATE FIRE MARSHALL IS A
ENTITY WITHIN CAL FIRE FOR THE
RECORD [inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
WE OKAY GO AHEAD AND FINISH AND
IT'S SORRY.
I'VE CONCLUDE MY CUSTOM.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY BUT I JUST
WASN'T SURE OUR COST ESTIMATES
ARE SO DIFFERENT.
THIS IS NOT A CANDIDATE FOR
SUSPENSE --
SO WOULD YOU LIKE IT IS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION WHICH I
CLOSE.
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU SO MUCH
AND AGAIN OF WHAT OTHER CITIES
THAT THE BILL IS AN ESTIMATE
ONGOING COSTS A HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS THE GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY --
WHICH WE BELIEVE IS AN IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT GOING TO KEEP
RESIDENTS SAFE I AND WE WILL BE
MORE THAN WILLING TO BE A FOLLOW
UP AND I WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE TO BE ABLE.
TO RECONCILE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
INVOLVE YOUR STAFF AS WELL.
THANK YOU APPRECIATE HAPPY TO
PARTICIPATE IN THE ONGOING COMES.
IT'S GREAT YEAH AND I'M SORRY WE
RARELY HAVE SUCH A DIFFERENT
VIEW ON THIS TICKET COST SO.
I WILL GO AHEAD AND THAT GETS
OUT WITH THE REPUBLICANS NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WE WILL
FOLLOW UP UP WITH BOTH YOURSELF
YOUR STAFF IS WELL AS DEPARTMENT
POINTS I APPRECIATE THAT THANK
YOU.
MISS RATES IS GOING TO PRESENT
FOR MISS JACKSON.
S. B..
NINE FORTY SEVEN MOW THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ON BEHALF OF SENATOR JACKSON.
SOME A BILL NINE FORTY SEVEN
LEGISLATION TO CREATE A PROCESS
FOR PARENTS STUDENTS.
EDUCATORS ANOTHER EDUCATIONAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO COLLABORATE WITH
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ON TOOLS AND BEST
PRACTICES.
I TEACH DIGITAL CITIZENSHIP
MEDIA LITERACY AND THE SAFE USE
OF TECHNOLOGY.
WITH US TODAY AND SUPPORT IS
DANIELLE KENDO KAISER OF COMMON
SENSE KIDS ACTION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS DANIEL CAN A KAISER ON
BEHALF OF COMMON SENSE KIDS
ACTION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION IS THE
LEGISLATIVE ARM OF COMMON SENSE
MEDIA.
S. B. NINE FOUR SEVEN ADDRESSES
THE NEW REALITY THAT IT'S NO
LONGER ENOUGH TO TEACH OUR KIDS
TO BE GOOD CITIZENS IN THE REAL
WORLD BUT ALSO IN THE ONLINE
SPACE.
COMMON SENSE KIDS ACTION AND
STOP FROM SENATOR JACKSON'S
OFFICE HAVE MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS. TO OUTLINE
THE PROPOSED WORK OF THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL AS DEFINED IN
S. B. EIGHT FOUR AND NINE FOUR
SEVEN WE THINK THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION FOR THEIR INPUT AND
LIMITING THE COST OF THE
PROPOSED MEETINGS WHILE ENSURING
THAT THE IMPORTANT WORK OF
CREATING.
A CLEAR PATH TO TEACHING OUR KEY
THROUGH TWELVE STUDENTS HOW TO
SAFELY AND WISELY USE TECHNOLOGY.
IN CLASSES AND IN THEIR HOME WE
URGE OUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS --
GOING CHAIR MEMBERS US AND
NATIONAL LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE EXISTING HISTORY
SOCIAL SCIENCE FRAMEWORK WHICH
WAS ADOPTED IN.
TWENTY SIXTEEN ALREADY INCLUDES
COMPONENTS OF MEDIA LITERACY IN
THE TIMELINE REQUIRED BY THE
LEGISLATION FOR THE SCOOP WORK
IS NOT FEASIBLE.
OF THIS BILL RESULTS IN A ONE
TIME NON PROP NINETY GENERAL
FUND COST THE PRICE ME TEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS.
THINK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE
TECH ATTACK ON BE ROLL CALL WITH
MR OBERNOLTE VOTING HIGH.
AND YOU WILL PRESENT.
I'M S. B. TEN THIRTY FIVE AS
WELL FLOOR THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR YES JACKSON.
CALL ME MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LED
FOR SECOND WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MISTER QUIRK A SECOND BY MISS
CARILLO.
I'D LIKE 2% SENATE BILL ON
BEHALF OF THE SENATE BILL TEN
THIRTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF SENATOR
JACKSON.
A BILL THAT ESTABLISHES A CLEAR
FREQUENT AND FLEXIBLE UPDATE
REQUIREMENT FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. TO FOLLOW WHEN
ADDRESSING CLIMATE ADAPTATION
AND RESILIENCY IN THEIR GENERAL
PLANNING.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
A SPEAKERS OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
OF WE HAVE A NEUTRAL POSITION ON
THIS BILL --
NO FISCAL IMPACT.
THANK YOU PROJECT BECAUSE I CAN
HAVE A SENATOR JACKSON I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
DON'T LIKE TO TALK ON THE ROLL
CALL THANK YOU FOR FILLING AND
AS A RESULT WE HAVE CONCLUDED.
THIS HEARING [inaudible]
A GERMAN